The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: So this
is a pretty key lecture.
This lecture is about principal
component analysis, PCA--
which is a major tool in
understanding a matrix of data.
So what is PCA about?
Well first of all,
let me remember what
was the whole point of last--
yesterday's lecture-- the
singular value decomposition,
that any matrix A could be
broken into r rank 1 pieces--
r being the rank of the matrix.
And each piece has a
U times a V transpose.
And the good-- special thing
is, the U's are orthonormal,
and also, the V's
are orthonormal.
OK.
So that's the whole matrix.
But we have a big
matrix, and we want
to get the important
information out of it--
not all the information.
And people say, in
machine learning,
if you've learned all the
training data, you haven't
learned anything, really.
You've just copied it all in.
The whole point of neural
nets and the process
of machine learning is to learn
important facts about the data.
And now, here we're at the
most basic stage of that.
And I claim that the important
facts about the matrix
are in its largest
k singular values--
the largest k pieces.
We can take-- k
equal 1 would tell us
the largest single piece.
But maybe we have space
and computing power
to handle a hundred pieces.
So I would take k equal 100.
The matrix might have
ranked thousands.
So I claim that Ak is the best.
Now here's the one theorem
for today, that Ak--
using the first k
pieces of the SVD--
is the best approximation
to A of rank k.
So I'll write that down.
So that really says
why the SVD is perfect.
OK.
So that statement
says, that if B--
another matrix-- has rank k,
then the distance from A to B--
the error you're making
in just using B--
that error is greater
than or equal to the error
you make for the best guy.
Now that's a pretty
straightforward,
beautiful fact.
And it goes back to
people who discovered
the SVD in the first place.
But then a couple
of psychologists
gave a proof in a later paper--
and it's often called
the Eckart-Young Theorem.
There is the theorem.
Isn't that straightforward?
And the hypothesis
is straightforward.
That's pretty nice.
But of course, we have
to think, why is it true?
Why is it true?
And to give meaning
to the theorem,
we have to say what
these double bars are.
Do you know the
right name for this?
So that double bar around
a matrix is called the--
the norm of the
matrix, the norm.
So I have to say something
about matrix norms.
How big is-- that's a
measure of how big it is.
And what I have to say is, there
are many different measures
of a matrix--
how large that matrix is.
Let me tell you, for today,
three possible measures
of a matrix.
So different ways to measure--
I'll call the matrix
just A, maybe.
But then I'm going to apply
the measure to A minus B,
and to A minus AK, and
show that that is smaller.
OK.
So I want to tell you
about the norm of A--
about some possible norms of
A. And actually, the norms I'm
going to take today will be--
will have the special feature
that they can be found--
computed by their
singular values.
So let me mention the L2 norm.
That is the largest
singular value.
So that's an important
measure of the--
sort of the size of a matrix.
I'm talking here about
a general m by n matrix
A. Sigma 1 is an
important norm--
often called the L2 norm.
And that's where
that index 2 goes.
Oh.
I should really
start with vectors--
norms of vectors-- and then
build to the norms of matrices.
Let me do norms of
vectors over on this side.
The L2 norm of a vector--
do we know what that is?
That's the regular length of
the vector that we all expect--
the square root of v1
squared up to vn squared.
The hypotenuse-- the
length of the hypotenuse
in n dimensional space.
That's the L2 norm,
because of that 2.
The L1 norm of a vector is
just add up those pieces
without squaring and
square rooting them.
Just add them.
That's the L1 norm.
And you might say, why
do we want two norms?
Or there are more norms.
Let me just tell you one more.
The infinity norm-- and there
is a reason for the 1 and the 2
and the infinity--
is the largest of the v's.
OK.
Have you met norms before?
I don't know.
These are vector norms,
but maybe you have met.
Then we're going to have matrix
norms, that maybe will be new.
So this is the norm that
we usually think of.
But this one has become
really, really important,
and let me tell you just why.
And then we'll-- later section
of the notes and a later
lecture in this course
will develop that--
develop this.
This is the L1 norm.
So this is L2, L1,
and L infinity--
[INAUDIBLE]
So what's special
about this one?
Well, it just turned out--
and it was only discovered
in our lifetimes--
that when you minimize some
function using the L1 norm,
you minimize some, let's
say, signal the noise,
or whatever you minimize--
some function.
If you use L1, the
winning vector--
the minimizing vector--
turns out to be sparse.
And what does sparse mean?
Sparse means mostly
zero components.
Somehow, when I minimize in L2--
which historically
goes back to Gauss,
the greatest
mathematician of all time.
When you minimize something in
L2, you do the least squares.
And you find that the guy
that gives you the minimum
has a lot of little numbers--
lot of little components.
Because when you're
square those little ones,
they don't hurt much.
But Gauss-- so Gauss
didn't do least L1 norm.
That has different
names-- basis pursuit.
And it comes into signal
processing and sensing.
Right.
And then it was discovered
that if you minimize--
as we'll see in that norm--
you amazingly get-- the
winning vector has--
is mostly zeros.
And the advantage of that
is that you can understand
what its components are.
The one with many
small components,
you have no interpretation
for that answer.
But for an answer that just
has a few non-zero components,
you really see what's happening.
And then this is a
important one, too.
OK.
Now I'm going to
turn just to-- so
what's the property of a norm?
Well, you can see that the
norm of C times a vector is--
just multiplying by
6, or 11, or minus
pi, or whatever-- is
the size of C. Norms
have that nice property.
They're homogeneous,
or whatever word.
If you double the vector,
you should double the norm--
double the length.
That makes sense.
And then the important
property is that--
is the famous
triangle in equality--
that if v and w are two
sides of a triangle,
and you take the norm of v
and add to the norm of w--
the two sides--
you get more than the straight
norm along the hypotenuse.
Yeah.
So those are properties
that we require,
and the fact that the norm
is positive, which is--
I won't write down.
But it's important too.
OK.
So those are norms, and
those will apply also
to matrix norms.
So if I double the matrix,
I want to double its norm.
And of course, that
works for that 2 norm.
And actually, probably-- so the
triangle in equality for this
norm is saying that the largest
singular value of A plus B--
two matrices-- is less
or equal to the larger
the singular value of A plus
the largest singular value of B.
And that's-- we won't take
class time to check minor,
straightforward
things like that.
So now I'm going to continue
with the three norms
that I want to tell you about.
That's a very important one.
Then there is another
norm that's named--
has an F. And it's
named after Frobenius.
Sorry about that.
And what is that norm?
That norm looks at all the
entries in the matrix--
just like it was a long vector--
and squares them all,
and adds them up.
So in a way, it's like
the 2 norm for a vector.
It's-- so the squared--
or shall I put square root?
Maybe I should.
It's the square root of all the
little people in the matrix.
So a1, n squared, plus the
next a2, 1 squared, and so on.
You finally get
to a-m-n squared.
You just treat the matrix
like a long vector.
And take this square
root just like so.
That's the Frobenius norm.
And then finally,
not so well known,
is something that's
more like L1.
It's called the nuclear norm.
And not all the faculty would
know about this nuclear norm.
So it is the sum of the
sigma of the singular values.
I guess there are r of them.
So that's where we would stop.
Oh, OK.
So those are three norms.
Now why do I pick on
those three norms?
And here's the point--
that for those three norms,
this statement is true.
I could cook up
other matrix norms
for which this wouldn't work.
But for these three
highly important norms,
this Eckart-Young statement,
that the closest rank k
approximation is found
from the first k pieces.
You see, that's a good
thing, because this is
what we compute from the SVD.
So now we've solved an
approximation problem.
We found the best B is Ak.
And the point is, it could use
all the-- any of those norms.
So there would be a--
well, somebody finally
came up with a proof that
does all three norms at once.
In the notes, I do that one
separately from Frobenius.
And actually, I found--
in an MIT thesis--
I was just reading a
course 6 PhD thesis--
and the author-- who is speaking
tomorrow, or Friday in IDSS--
Dr. [? Cerebro ?] found a
nice new proof of Frobenius.
And it's in the notes, as
well as an older proof.
OK.
You know, as I talk
here, I'm not too sure
whether it is essential for
me to go through the proof,
either in the L2 norm--
which takes half a
page in then notes--
or in the Frobenius
norm, which takes more.
I'd rather you see the point.
The point is that, in
these norms-- and now,
what is special about
these norms of a matrix?
These depend only
on the sigmas--
only on the-- oh.
Oh.
I'll finish that sentence,
because it was true.
These norms depend only
on the singular values.
Right?
That one, at least, depends
only on the singular value.
It's the largest one.
This one is the sum of them all.
This one comes into the Netflix
competition, by the way.
This was the right norm to win
a zillion dollars in the Netflix
competition.
So what did Netflix put--
it did a math competition.
It had movie preferences from
many, many Netflix subscribers.
They gave their ranking
to a bunch of movies.
But of course,
they hadn't seen--
none of them had
seen all the movies.
So the matrix of rankings--
where you had the
ranker and the matrix--
is a very big matrix.
But it's got missing entries.
If the ranker didn't see
the movie, he isn't--
he or she isn't ranking it.
So what's the idea
about Netflix?
So they offered like a
million dollar prize.
And a lot of math and
computer science people
fought for that prize.
And over the years, they got
like higher 92, 93, 94% right.
But it turned out
that this was--
well, you had to--
in the end, you had to
use a little psychology
of how people voted.
So it was partly about
human psychology.
But it was also a very
large matrix problem
with an incomplete matrix--
an incomplete matrix.
And so it had to be completed.
You had to figure out
what would the ranker have
said about the post
if he hadn't seen it,
but had ranked several
other movies, like All
the President's
Men, or whatever--
given a ranking to those?
You have to-- and that's a
recommender system, of course.
That's how you get
recommendations from Amazon.
They've got a big
matrix calculation here.
And if you've bought a
couple of math books,
they're going to tell you
about more math books--
more than you want to know.
Right.
OK.
So anyway, it just
turned out that this norm
was the right one to minimize.
I can't give you all the details
of the Netflix competition,
but this turned out
to be the right norm
to do a minimum problem,
a best not least squares.
These squares would
look at some other norm,
but a best nuclear norm
completion of the matrix.
And that-- and now it's--
so now it's being put to much
more serious uses for MRI--
magnetic resonance stuff,
when you go in and get--
it's a noisy system,
but you get--
it gives a excellent
picture of what's going on.
So I'll just write Netflix here.
So it gets in the--
and then MRIs.
So what's the point about MRIs?
So if you don't--
if you stay in long enough,
you get all the numbers.
There isn't missing data.
But if you-- as with a child--
you might want to
just have the child
in for a few
minutes, then that's
not enough to get
a complete picture.
And you have,
again, missing data
in your matrix in the
image from the MRI.
So then, of course, you've
got to complete that matrix.
You have to fill in,
what would the MRI have
seen in those positions where
it didn't look long enough?
And again, a nuclear norm
is a good one for that.
OK.
So there will be a whole section
on norms, maybe just about--
in stellar by now.
OK.
So I'm not going to--
let me just say,
what does this say?
What does this tell us?
I'll just give an example.
Maybe I'll take-- start with
the example that's in the notes.
Suppose k is 2.
So I'm looking among
all rank 2 matrices.
And suppose my matrix is 4,
3, 2, 1, and all the rest 0's.
Diagonal.
And it's rank 4 matrix.
I can see its singular values.
They're sitting there.
Those would be the singular
values, and the eigenvalues,
and everything, of course.
Now, what would be A2?
What would be the
best approximation
of rank 2 to that matrix, in
this sense to be completed?
What would A2 do?
Yeah.
It would be 4 and 3.
It would pick the two largest.
So I'm looking at Ak.
This is k to the 2, so
it has to have rank 2.
This has got rank 4.
The biggest pieces are those.
OK.
So this thing says that if
I had any other matrix B,
it would be further away
from A than this guy.
It says that this
is the closest.
And I just-- could you think
of a matrix that could possibly
be closer, and be rank 2?
Rank two 2 the tricky thing.
The matrices of rank 2
form a kind of crazy set.
If I add a rank 2 matrix
to a rank 2 matrix,
probably the rank is up to 4.
So the rank 2 matrices are
all kind of floating around
in their own little corners.
This looks like the best one.
But in the notes I suggest,
well, you could get a rank 2--
well, what about B?
What about this B?
For this guy, I
could get closer--
maybe not exact-- but closer,
maybe by taking 3.5, 3.5.
But I only want to use rank--
I've only got two
rank 2 to play with.
So I better make
this into a rank--
I have to make this into
a rank 1 piece, and then
the 2 and the 1.
So you see what I--
what I thought of?
I thought, man,
maybe that's better--
like on the diagonal,
I'm coming closer.
Well, I'm not getting
it exactly here.
But then I've got one
left to play with.
And I'll put, maybe,
1.5 down here.
OK.
So that's a rank 2 matrix--
two little rank 1s.
And on the diagonal,
it's better.
3.5s-- I'm only
missing by a half.
1.5s-- I'm missing by half.
So I'm only missing by
a half on the diagonal
where this guy was missing by 2.
So maybe I've found
something better.
But I had to pay a price of
these things off the diagonal
to keep the rank low.
And they kill me.
So that B will be
further away from A.
The error, if I computed A
minus B, and computed its norm,
I would see bigger
than A minus A2.
Yeah.
So, you see the
point of the theorem?
That's really what I'm trying
to say, that it's not obvious.
You may feel, well,
it's totally obvious.
Pick 4 and 3.
What else could do it?
But it depends on
the norm and so on.
So it's not--
Eckart-Young had to think of a
proof, and other people, too.
OK.
So that's-- now, but you
could say-- also say--
object that I started with
a diagonal matrix here.
That's so special.
But what I want to say
is the diagonal matrix
is not that special,
because I could take A--
so let me now just call
this diagonal matrix D--
or let me call it
sigma to give it
another sort of
appropriate name.
So if I thought of
matrices, what I want to say
is, this could be
the sigma matrix.
And there could be a
U on the left of it,
and a sigma on the right of it.
So A is U sigma V transpose.
So this is my sigma.
And this is like any
orthogonal matrix U.
And this is like
any V transpose.
Right?
I'm just saying, here's a
whole lot more matrices.
There is just one matrix.
But now, I have
all these matrices
with Us multiplying on the
left, and V transpose ones
on the right.
And I ask you this
question, what
are the singular values
of that matrix, A?
Here the singular
values were clear--
4, 3, 2, and 1.
What are the singular
values of this matrix A,
when I've multiplied by a
orthogonal guy on both sides?
That's a key question.
What are the singular
values of that one?
AUDIENCE: 4, 3, 2, 1.
GILBERT STRANG: 4, 3, 2, 1.
Didn't change.
Why is that?
Because the singular
values are the--
because this has a SVD form--
orthogonal times diagonal
times orthogonal.
And that diagonal contains
the singular values.
What I'm saying is, that my--
and our-- trivial little
example here, actually
was all 4 by 4's that have
these singular values.
I could-- my whole problem
is orthogonally invariant,
a math guy would say.
When I multiply by U or
a V transpose, or both--
the problem doesn't change.
Norms don't change.
Yeah, that's a point.
Yeah.
I realize it now.
This is the point.
If I multiply the matrix A
by an orthogonal matrix U,
it has all the same norms--
doesn't change the norm.
Actually, that was true way back
for vectors with this length--
with this length.
What's the deal about vectors?
Suppose I have a vector
V, and I've computed
its hypotenuse and the norm.
And now I look at Q times
V in that same 2 norm.
What's special about that?
So I took any vector V and
I know what its length is--
hypotenuse.
Now I multiply by Q.
What happens to the length?
Doesn't change.
Orthogonal matrix--
you could think
of it as just like rotating
the triangle in space.
The hypotenuse doesn't change.
And we've checked that,
because we could--
the check is to square it.
And then you're doing
QV, transpose QV.
And you simplify
it the usual way.
And then you have Q transpose
Q equal the identity.
And you're golden.
Yeah.
So the result is you get
the same answer as V.
So let me put it in a
sentence now, pause.
Multiplying that norm is not
changed by orthogonal matrix.
And these norms are not
changed by orthogonal matrices,
because if I multiply the A
here by an orthogonal matrix,
I have--
this is my A. If
i multiply by a Q,
then I have QU
sigma V transpose.
And what is really
the underlying point?
That QU is an orthogonal matrix
just as good as U. So if I--
let me put this down.
QA would be QU
sigma V transpose.
And now I'm asking you,
what's the singular value
decomposition for QA?
And I hope I may
actually-- seeing it.
What's the singular value
decomposition of QA?
What are the singular values?
What's the diagonal matrix?
Just look there for it.
The diagram matrix is sigma.
What goes on the right of it?
The V transpose.
And what goes on the
left of it is QU.
Plus, that's orthogonal
times orthogonal.
Everybody in this
room has to know
that if I multiply two
orthogonal matrices,
the result is,
again, orthogonal.
So I can multiply by Q, and it
only affects the U part, not
the sigma part.
And so it doesn't change
any of those norms.
OK.
So that's fine.
That's what I wanted to
say about the Eckart-Young
Theorem--
not proving it, but
hopefully giving you
an example there
of what it means--
that this is the best rank
to approximate that one.
OK.
So that's the key
math behind PCA.
So now I have to--
want to, not just have to--
but want to tell you about PCA.
So what's that about?
So we have a bunch of
data, and we want to see--
so let me take a bunch of data--
bunch of data points--
say, points in the plane.
So I have a bunch of
data points in the plane.
So here's my data vector.
First, vector x1-- well, x.
Is at a good--
maybe v1.
These are just two
component guys.
v2.
They're just columns
with two components.
So I'm just measuring
height and age,
and I want to find the
relationship between height
and age.
So the first row is meant--
is the height of my data.
And the second row is the ages.
So these are-- so I've
got say a lot of people,
and these are the heights
and these are the ages.
And I've got n points in 2D.
And I want to make
sense out of that.
I want to look for the
relationship between height
and age.
I'm actually going to look
for a linear row relation
between height and age.
So first of all, these
are all over the place.
So the first step that
a statistician does,
is to get mean 0.
Get the average to be 0.
So what is-- so all these
points are all over the place.
From row 1, the height, I
subtract the average height.
So this is A-- the matrix I'm
really going to work on is
my matrix A-- minus
the average height--
well, in all components.
So this is a, a, a, a--
I'm subtracting the mean, so
average height and average age.
Oh, that was a
brilliant notation,
a sub a can't be a sub a.
You see what the
matrix has done--
this matrix 2 means?
It's just made each row
of A. Now adds to row.
Now add to what?
If I have a bunch
of things, and I've
subtracted off their mean--
so the mean, or the
average is now 0--
then those things add up to--
AUDIENCE: Zero.
GILBERT STRANG: Zero.
Right.
I've just brought these points
into something like here.
This is age, and this is height.
And let's see.
And by subtracting,
it no longer is
unreasonable to have negative
age and negative height,
because--
so, right.
The little kids, when I
subtract it off the average age,
they ended up with
a negative age.
The older ones ended
up still positive.
And somehow, I've got
a whole lot of points,
but hopefully, their
mean is now zero.
Do you see that I've
centered the data at 0, 0?
And I'm looking for-- what
am I looking for here?
I'm looking for the best line.
That's what I want to find.
And that would be
a problem in PCA.
What's the best linear relation?
Because PCA is limited.
PCA isn't all of deep
learning by any means.
The whole success
of deep learning
was the final realization,
after a bunch of years,
that they had to have a
nonlinear function in there
to get to model serious data.
But here's PCA as
a linear business.
And I'm looking
for the best line.
And you will say, wait a minute.
I know how to find the best
line, just use least squares.
Gauss did it.
Can't be all bad.
But PCA-- and I
was giving a talk
in New York when I was
just learning about it.
And somebody said,
what you're doing
with PCA has to be the
same as least squares--
it's finding the best line.
And I knew it wasn't,
but I didn't know how
to answer that question best.
And now, at least,
I know better.
So the best line
in least squares--
can I remind you
about least squares?
Because this is
not least squares.
The best line of least squares--
so I have some data points.
And I have a best line
that goes through them.
And least squares, I don't
always center the data
to mean zero, but I could.
But what do you minimize
in least squares--
least squares?
If you remember the
picture in linear algebra
books of least squares,
you measure the errors--
the three errors.
And it's how much you're
wrong at those three points.
Those are the three errors.
A-- difference
between Ax and B--
the B minus Ax that you square.
And you add up
those three errors.
And what's different over here?
I mean, there's more points,
but that's not the point.
That's not the difference.
The difference is, in PCA,
you're measuring perpendicular
to the line.
You're adding up all these
little guys, squaring them.
So you're adding up their
squares and minimizing.
So the points-- you see
it's a different problem?
And therefore it has
a different answer.
And this answer turns out to
involve the SVD, the sigmas.
Where this answer, you remember
from ordinary linear algebra,
just when you
minimize that, you got
to an equation that leads to
what equation for the best x?
So do you remember?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: Yeah.
What is it now?
Everybody should know.
And we will actually
see it in this course,
because we're doing the
heart of linear algebra here.
We haven't done it yet, though.
And tell me again, what equation
do I solve for that problem?
AUDIENCE: A transpose A.
GILBERT STRANG: A transpose
A x hat equal A transpose b.
Called the normal equations.
It's sort part of--
it's this regression
in statistics language.
That's a regression problem.
This is a different problem.
OK.
Just so now you see the answer.
So that involves--
well, they both
involve A transpose A.
That's sort of interesting,
because you have a
rectangular matrix A,
and then sooner or later,
A transpose A is coming.
But this involves solving a
linear system of equations.
So it's fast.
And we will do it.
And it's very important.
It's probably the most
important application in 18.06.
But it's not the
same as this one.
So this is now in 18.06,
maybe the last day is PCA.
So I didn't put those letters--
Principal Component
Analysis-- PCA.
Which statisticians have
been doing for a long time.
We're not doing
something brand new here.
But the result is that we--
so how does a statistician
think about this problem,
or that data matrix?
What-- if you have
a matrix of data--
2 by 2 rows and many columns--
so many, many samples--
what-- and we've
made the mean zero.
So that's a first
step a statistician
takes to check on the mean.
What's the next step?
What else does a
statistician do with data
to measure how-- its size?
There's another number.
There's a number that
goes with the mean,
and it's the variance--
the mean and the variance.
So somehow we're
going to do variances.
And it will really be
involved, because we
have two sets of data--
heights and ages.
We're really going to
have a covariance--
covariance matrix--
and it will be 2 by 2.
Because it will tell us not only
the variance in the heights--
that's the first
thing a statistician
would think about--
some small people,
some big people--
and variation in ages--
but also the link between them.
How are the height, age pairs--
does more height-- does more
age go with more height?
And of course, it does.
That's the whole point here.
So it's this covariance matrix.
And that covariance matrix--
or the sample covariance matrix,
to give it its full name--
what's the-- so just touching
on statistics for a moment here.
What's the-- when we see that
word sample in the name, what
is that telling us?
It's telling us that this matrix
is computed from the samples,
not from a theoretical
probability distribution.
We might have a
proposed distribution
that the height
follows the age--
height follows the
age by some formula.
And that would give us
theoretical variances.
We're doing sample
variances, also called
empirical covariance made.
Empirical says--
empirical-- that word
means, from the
information, from the data.
So that's what we do.
And it is exactly--
it's AA transpose.
You have to normalize it by
the number of data points, N.
And then, for some reason--
best known to statisticians--
it's N minus 1.
And of course, they've
got to be right.
They've been around a long time
and it should be N minus 1,
because somehow 1
degree of freedom
was accounted for
when we took away--
when we made the mean 0.
So we-- anyway, no problem.
But the N minus 1 is not going
to affect our computation here.
This is the matrix
that tells us that's
what we've got to work with.
That's what we've got to work
with-- the matrix AA transpose.
And then the-- so we
have this problem.
So we have a--
yeah.
I guess we really have
a minimum problem.
We want to find--
yeah.
What problem are we solving?
And it's-- yeah.
So our problem was
not least squares--
not the same as least squares.
Similar, but not the same.
We want to minimize.
So we're looking
for that best line
where age equals some number,
c, times the height, times the--
yeah-- or height.
Maybe it would have been better
to age here and height here.
No.
No, because there
are two unknowns.
So I'm looking for c.
I'm looking for the number c--
looking for the number c.
And with just two minutes in
class left, what is that number
c going to be, when I finally
get the problem stated
properly, and then solve it?
I'm going to learn that the
best ratio of age to height
is sigma 1.
Sigma 1.
That's the one that tells us
how those two are connected,
and the orthogonal-- and
what will be the best--
yeah.
No.
Maybe I didn't answer
that the right--
maybe I didn't get that right.
Because I'm looking for--
I'm looking for the vector
that points in the right way.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I think the answer is, it's
got to be there in the SVD.
I think it's the
vector you want.
It's the principal
component you want.
Let's do that
properly on Friday.
I hope you see--
because this was
a first step away
from the highlights
of linear algebra
to problem solve
by linear algebra,
and practical
problems, and my point
is that the SVD solves these.